your money goes
really to consider
um before I ask my usual
question just a plea that if you can
remember to bring your name plates it
helps me a great deal because I can call
in you more easily I know you have a lot
on your mind so if you forget it's not a
big deal but if you can remember that'll
be
great so let me jump to the question
that I'm promised you I would ask at the
start of every class at least through
the first couple of weeks how many of
you have not picked a company to Value
yet notice the framing of the question
has changed how many of you have not
picked a
company you do realize that I can look
at the master
list and see how many have not picked
right so this is like a rhetorical
question there are still quite a few of
you who haven't picked a company or you
haven't end the master list either way
please fix it no because as you will see
if you have a company an actual company
to work with Things become more tangible
right risk-free rates risk premiums
betas cost of capital cash flows it's
easier if you actually have a real
company to work with rather than
abstractions I also want to ask a
question about groups I know there are a
few people are still struggling to find
groups is there anybody in this class
who's not in a group
yet I would like the other groups to see
if they have room for an extra person
because I'm going to put up show up for
adoption here and he's a very good
person to have in your group he's
promised me pick pick the young high
growth money losing company for
you but um please so that's that's the
only nudging I can do so hopefully
somebody will approach you after this
class so let's talk about risk
rates but but today actually as the
start of the class I'm going to talk
about the thing that we're going to move
to after risk rates which is equity risk
premiums let me frame what we're trying
to
estimate the risk free rate is what you
guaranteed to make right and we talked
about how to get it for a currency where
it's easy maybe the Swiss frank maybe
the US dollar and even where it's
difficult the Indian rupe the Brazilian
R let's say the risk free rate let's do
stay in dollars right now the t- bond
rate at the start of today was about 4
and a half% so you can put your money
into a t-bond for the next 10 years and
you're guaranteed 2 4 and half% with the
caveat being that the US Treasury might
default but let's keep that out of the
picture 2 half% you know what the equity
risk premium is it's what you would
demand over and above that 4 and a half%
to invest in equities as a
class let's start with the easy part of
that question if you can make 4 and a
half% guarantee would you demand a
higher return or a lower return for
investing in equities as a class as an
expected return You demand more right
the actual returns might be lower that's
a risk
but it would be crazy to say I'll take 3
and a half% on stocks if you can make 4
and a half% guarantee the equity risk
free is that extra number you would
charge and already you can see why this
is going to be so difficult to estimate
will it be different across the people
in this
room and what drives those
differences risk aversion if you're more
risk aversion you'll charge a higher
Prem doesn't make it right or wrong it's
just differences and we're trying to
estimate one number for the entire
Market think of the millions of people
people in this market you can't go
around ask how risk ofe are you how risk
ofe are you and then try to figure it
out so we' struggled with how best to
estimate the number 95% of valuations
here's how that number gets estimated
people Look
Backwards what does that mean to
estimate what you can make over and
above the risk free rate you look at 100
Years of stock market history in the US
and you look at what stocks have earned
over and above something that you call
RIS Treasures for let's say that's 3%
say that's what I earned in the last 100
years that's what I can expect to make
in the
future first when you do this what are
you assuming about the
future it's going to look like the past
it's called mean reversion but you
assume that the past will look like the
is that a bad good assumption no don't
be so quick to say no because we do this
all the time in valuation right we use
margins we so if you say no here I'm
going to come back and haunt you for the
rest of this class cuz we assume mean
reversion some things and we don't
assume mean reversion others so let me
reframe the
question under what conditions is it
okay to assume mean
reversion to
you long is one condition so that that's
a statistical requirement but it's more
than just long right for the future to
look like the past the system has to be
pretty
stable there can't be a structural rate
I'll give you an example
say you sign Justin berlanda San
Francisco
Giants it's legendary pictures one four
with five S Young his lifetime erra is
like 2 point something which is if you
have not not track baseball is a really
good erra and the giant
silent historically he's won like 16 to
20 games a
season so I'm going to use me R version
assume that he's going to win 20 games
next season Jacob what's the problem
with my assumption
you follow baseball will be unfair to
ask you if not I don't follow anybody
who's a baseball fan tell me what's get
up there he's 40 years
old there's been a structural break
right which is at 40 you're fighting all
kinds of things you're definitely not
going to be winning 20 games and you
could do the soccer play Lion Messi if
you sign them on now as bar are you
going to go back to the top of the
league I don't think so
there's been a structural break mean
reversion works until it does it so
what's the question I'm asking about the
US market is the US Equity Market going
forward like the market of the last 100
years or has there been a structural
break and I'll give you a clue until
2008 I used to have give leeway to
people using historical risk premiums in
the US looking backwards that's you
saying what happened in 2008 well that's
a question that shouldn't be asked
because we know exactly what 2008
brought us it brought us a reminder that
we were in the 21st century it took us
eight years into the century say hey
you're not in the 20th century anymore
that this was no longer an economy where
the US was the global economy that we
were truly a global economy everybody
locked at the
head and that the risk premiums for the
last century are probably not the right
risk premum for the future even if they
were right for the last century and
that's a statistical question Julian
raises how do I even know what the risk
premium was over the last century
there's a statistical question we'll
have to examine but there's a structural
question as I said 95% evaluation the
assumption is we'll revert back to the
past so we're going to start with that
process and ask some mechanical
questions about that
process but let's say you decide to stay
with the status quo estimate a
historical risk
rate to get that historical risk premium
for the US and I'm going to give you
some choices about time
periods I want you to tell me what time
period you're going to use to get a
historical risk premium you could use
just the last
year in which case what's your RIS
premium going to look like what it
stocks through last year Jacob
25% you know what the t- bond rate was
last year the return on T bonds was
minus
1.6% how did the return become negative
last year what happened happened last
year to make the t- bond return
negative the coupon rates were positive
but the interest rates went up the price
of the bond decreased so if I looked at
last year Equity risk premum was about
26.6% what's the problem with using
that well because last year was a really
good year we know you know any sense of
Comon that this is not going to be the
case going forward so one year it's too
short a period right how about five
years
or 10
years what's a test of when a period is
long enough that you can trust a number
what have we taught in statistics that
allows us to gauge the trustworthiness
of a
number comput you comput but Cycles are
tough to guess in the market right
there's a standard error what does it
come from how volatile stock returns
over time and if stock returns a vol
that standard error is going to be large
and the standard error is large I can
give you an estimate but if I'm you know
following the path of Truth and
advertising I have to say this is the
range on that
estimate so one year only do five years
or do 10 100 years even is not quite
enough you're going to see shockingly
large standard errors with 100 years so
even if you believe that the future is
going to look like the past you're going
to run into a second problem I can give
you a number but then I'm going to give
you a range on that number is so large
that you say what am I going to do with
this number I'm starting to dig a hole
for historical risk creams that I hope
to bury them in but the foundations are
first you can't assume the future is
going to look like the past and the
second is it's
noisy noisy in the sense of big standard
errors and there's a third problem with
historical R sprs they push in the wrong
direction let me explain what I mean by
this let's say 2022 2011 is too far in
the past 2022 was a terrible year for
stocks stocks were down about
24% let's assume I'm Computing a
historical risk premium right I computed
through 2021 now I had a really bad year
for stocks I bring in 2022 into my
calculation when I bring in a really bad
year of stock returns what's going to
happen to my risk premium is it going to
go down or go up it's going you brought
a really bad yeah negative number you
bring in a negative number your stock
returns are actually going to get lower
so your risk premium actually will go
down after a terrible year for stocks
intuitively think of what I'm asking you
to say you're in a crisis stock prices
drop 25% a year I said don't worry
things have become much safer use a
lower risk premium that's what I mean by
pushing in the wrong direction because
you think about risk is coming from your
gut my guess is after a really bad year
for stocks you're feeling more risk ofs
not less risk of ver you should demand a
higher premium but historic premiums are
going to push in the wrong
direction they're going to push up when
you're in a bull market and everybody's
optimistic they're going to push down
when you're in a crisis and that's not
the direction you want risk premiums to
go we've always known this about
historical risk premiums but you know
the argument that people use for using
historical risk premiums is right what
other choice do we
have how do we get a forward-looking
premium you can't go around asking
people people try with survey PR they're
so
unreliable so 30 years ago I decided
that this wasn't working for me I said I
want a forward-looking premium that's
Dynamic that changes if I'm in the
middle of a
crisis and I stole an idea from the bond
market Bond markets are not that
creative but this is an idea that I
like let's see how much of your
foundations class you remember how do
you compute the yield to maturity in a
bond diction what's what's a process by
which you compute the yield to maturity
on a
b the face value and what first before
you okay price and face value what else
do you look at and coupons During the
period so finish the process off I've
got the price I've got the coupons I got
the face value what's yeld to
maturity it's you bring it back it's
that discount rate that makes the
present value of the cash
flows there you go it's an internal rate
of return for a bond right
so I'm going to frame this and I'm going
to give you a very simple intuitive way
of thinking about Equity risk
BRS so Bradley is going to be my guinea
pig today okay so I told you the rates
right now 4 and a half% let's round it
up to 5% right let's suppose I promised
you a dollar in cash flows every year
forever in perpetuity and let's assume
that I have an entity that will keep
paying it up so even after I pass so if
I offered you a dollar every year in
perpetuity guaranteed how much would you
pay for that cash flow Stree uh it would
be one divided by the discount rate one
divided by 0.05 would give you $20 do
you see why $20 would do it because if
you took $20 and invested 5% what do you
make every year a dollar so basically it
works out so if dollar with certainty
every year in perpetuity would give me
$20 Julian I'm going to pick on you now
so now I'm going to give you the same
cash flow stream a dollar every year but
rather than it being guaranteed there's
going to be risk in it it's going to be
risk associated with the typical Equity
investment would you pay less than 20 or
more than 20 for
that less than 20 right why $20 for a
guaranteed cash flow this is now an
uncertain cash flow you're saying I'm
not paying 20 how much less give me a
number
$5 so think so that's a good good point
but the more risk less you'll pay right
so let's suppose this is the collective
risk of all equities in the US and it's
a subjective number so tell me you know
$12 $15 $10 what would you pay
for $13 right once he tells me that he's
given me his Equity risk premium do you
see why because if you make a dollar
every year and you pay $13 one divided
by 13 I wish she given me 10 it be a
nice number to work with but you know
you pay
would be what 7even so basically it's
about
7% 7% minus the 5% risk free rate gives
you an equity risk premium of 2% if
Margaret had told me $10 that's an
expected return of 10% the equity risk
PR is 5% you tell me what you pay for
something whether you like it or not
you've given away your Equity risk
premium right the less you pay the
higher the risk
premium today we're going to to bring
that maybe today I don't know whether
you'll get to it we're going to use that
same idea to get an equity risk bring
for
Stocks by doing what do we know what
people pay for stocks every minute of
every day right there's the index number
right
there do we know what expected cash
flows are not as easily as the example
that I gave you but we can estimate them
because we have history these are 500 if
it's S&P 500 there if earnings and cash
flows you can project them
out and and once I do that I can do
exactly what I did with a bond compute
an internal rate of return that makes
the present value of the cash flows it's
messier than a bond I agree but it's a
number that will be forward-looking
because it's based on expected future
cash flows and will it be
dynamic because every time the stock
index changes the risk premium is
changing remember last Monday when we
woke up to a tariff news and the index
was down 3%
when the index drops what's happening to
the risk
premium they go up just like bond prices
and interest rates that makes complete
sense right you walk up to a crisis your
risk premium goes up we're moving in the
right direction it's going to be forward
forward-looking and dynamic and it's a
number that we can track over time so
we're jumping ahead to that we'll we'll
get to that soon but first I want to
wrap up our discussion of risk free
rates now Julian just before the class
started you know asked me to mention
which packet so let me be clear know the
intro packet is done everything we're
going to do other than the start of the
class test is going to come from that
packet
one remember last session we were
talking about estimating a risk-free
rate in Brazilian
R we have the Government Bond R right
you say what if I have a currency with
no government bonds we'll talk about
that we have a government bond rate but
I said you can't use the government bond
rate as your rcre rate why not
what because governments have risk right
they might not pay you back so what do
we have to do we have to take out from
the government bond rate what we think
is due to that default risk and I gave
you three ways of doing it one is I said
if you can find a dollar or a Euro Bond
issued by that government you can take
the difference between that rate and the
t- bond rate so for the Brazilian
government that works out to be 3.17 7%
right you subtract the
3.17% from the government bond rate of
12.3% you get a risk free rate of
9.17% that's approach one but the
problem with that is government bonds
don't often get traded you might say I
don't trust the government bond rate so
let's try a second one I talked about
the Sovereign CDs Market if you've never
heard of it you're not alone lots of
people have it it's a way you buy
insurance against default risk
it's a market set number that number was
2.82% you subtract that from 12.3% you
get a risk-free rate in re of 99.48%
already you can say which one should I
use hang on I'll give you a third
one I say I don't trust the market I
don't trust the Government Bond but I
trust the ratings
agency a strange place to end up but it
based on its rating the default spre
2.83% you subtract that from the
12.3% if you just had to
pick the risk free rate which one's
going to give you the highest value the
lowest risk free rate or the highest one
looks like the lowest one right see this
is great I can pick whatever I want I'm
going to say something that's going to
sound nonsensical but I'll back it up it
doesn't matter which of the three
numbers you pick if you stay consistent
because you're going to come back with
to this number again later in the
calculation
I'm not going to be mysterious what are
the three numbers that go into my cost
of equity a risk free rate a bet and an
equity risk premium right you know what
this number is going to come back when I
compute the risk premium for Brazil so
if you pick a big default spread here
because it gives you a lower risk free
rate that same bigger default spread is
going to give you a bigger Equity risk
premium so it's actually good news
because it means don't pontificate about
which number to pick pick one and move
on and just remember which one you pick
that's the only requirement
it'll get it'll it'll even out so it is
true that those numbers could could
change but no you can estimate risk in
the case of Brazil I had all three in
the case of India I have two out of the
three which one is
missing I can find a sovereign CDs and I
can find a rating but India does not
issue dollar denominated
bonds but if I picked um Gambia
there are no government
bonds you're you're essentially in no
man's land basically because you might
not even be able to get a default spread
using any of the
approaches and maybe if you get a rating
that's all you can do so Beggars can't
be choosers the currency you pick there
might be only one way just take that and
move on with
it but if your inflation that's high we
talked about the possibility of doing
everything in real terms let's be very
clear in what that means
when you compute things in real terms
you're ignoring inflation it's called
constant dollars you're acting like the
only way you'll be able to grow your
revenues by selling more items you can
do your cash flows in real terms and
already you can see real cash flows will
generally be lower than noral cash flows
why because inflation is not helping you
so by itself you saying this is bad I'm
getting lower cash flows but to be
consistent then you have to use a real
discount rate that has to come from a
real risk
rad say how the heck am I going to get a
real risk ring for the last 20 plus
years and it's only in the last 20 plus
years in the US I talked about the tips
rate an inflation protected treasury
rate staying with the Assumption the
treasury doesn't default here's how the
tips Works a tips rate works right now
the tips rate I think is about 2.23% you
go by a 10year tips Bond the rate is
2.23% can somebody help me on what
exactly I will make every year on this
Bond how does this work go ahead it's
the rate plus the it'll be whatever The
observed inflation rate so let's say
next year the inflation rate is 3% I
will get 2.3 23% plus 3% what if it's 7%
I'll get 2.23 + 7% what if it's minus 1%
be 2.23 minus 1% you see what this does
right it guarantees you a real rate of
return not a ninal
return so you could argue it's a real
risk
R but I've almost never seen a valuation
in the US done in real terms and there's
a good reason for that the world
operates in noral
terms in fact this April 15 when you
file your taxes try this say look I took
the income from last year but I
inflation adjusted the income I really
didn't make
$150,000 in constant 2023 I made only
$121,000
I'd like to pay less in
taxes the IRS is going to say that's
nice but we tax nominal income the world
revolves around nominal numbers so it
does make sense to stay with nominal
numbers so why would use real numbers
because inflation gets so high and
unstable in some countries you finally
give up and say I'm going to do
everything in real terms Latin America
used to be the epicenter for real
analysis because inflation was such a
bogey man
and I need a real risk free rate for
those projects in Venezuela and Honduras
and Brazil and he say can I take the
tips rate which is a real risk rate r i
get in the US Treasury Market and use it
there I'll give you the easy answer
first and then I'll give you the
qualifiers
yes but only if you assume what what
keeps in in an e cont textbook real risk
fre rates should actually be the same
around the
world because the real risk fre rate in
Brazil is 4% it's 2.2% in the US what
should happen in that Capital should
flow
from don't let's not even use the word
arbitrage Capital flow where the real
returns are highest so you should have
Capital flowing from the US to Brazil
which will push the real rate down in
Brazil towards so in a world where
there's no limits to Capital flowing and
that's obviously utopian
world the real risk free rate is a real
risk free rate no matter where you are
I'm going to hold on to that word
because the alternative to me is
terrifying in terms of estimating a real
and if you ask me to do a real valuation
of a Brazilian company I will start with
the 2.23% tips rate and hope and pray
that Capital flows enough for it not to
be too
different we'll come back and see maybe
there's different ways of doing it but
this is the only observable updated real
risk free rate you're going to be able
to
use and I'm going to take it and work
with it in spite of its
limitations so let's say I do this the
the what I did with the Brazilian re for
multiple currencies I they started 2025
here's what the world looked like to me
in terms of risk fre rates so you can
see that risk free rates so the way to
read this is the height of the column is
the government bond rate so let's take
turkey the Turkish Government Bond rate
is 27%
but there's default risk in Turkey you
subtract out that red part is a default
risk what you're left with is a risk
free rate in Turkish L of about
22% think just pause and think about
what that does right you start with a
22% base and you start adding stuff to
it what's your cost of backp putting
Capital going to look like really high
numbers yesterday I valued this Turkish
company called
Anor in Turkish l so it's an exercise
where you're saying will this hold up
because you're looking at 30% cost of
capital you think about discounting
trust me it's going to be okay you can
still value companies with 22 but you
can see that risk free rates vary across
currencies so I have a very simple
question I think we've kind of answered
in the last session let's kind of nail
it down remember me again why risk free
rates vary cross currency
sta why risk free rates why is the risk
free rate high in l
but remember I cleaned up for the risk
right so if I showed you Government Bond
rates that would explain it but if I
cleaned up for that risk what's
left you want to pass it on what do you
thinking High inflation currencies have
high risk free rates low inflation
currencies have low risk free rates and
deflationary currencies could have what
netive negative risk rats we've cracked
the code here that's exactly why
currency choice is not going to matter
you know Adil came to me at the start of
the class and he said I'm valuing a
Swiss company in Swiss
fra when I did this swis Frank rate was
mildly positive but he said it's turned
negative right now by itself if you
looked at a negative risk-free rate
you're going to end up with a really low
cost of
capital but a negative risk free rate
goes with deflation and low growth so
when you do your cash flows you have to
stay with s frack and the way it'll play
out is you said there operations were in
the U right so your cash flows are all
going to be in US dollars but to do your
valuation in Swiss Franks what do you
have to do you have to convert dollar
cash flows into Swiss frank cash flows
and what do you need for that you need
future exchange
rates and if your inflation rate is
minus. 2% and the inflation rate in the
US is
2.5% is in very general terms what
should happen to that exchange
rate that's TR appreciate right it's
called purchasing power par it's one of
the in fact The Economist used to have
this index called the Big Mac index
where they used to measure what a Big
Mac cost in different parts of the world
it was actually very good predictor what
exchange rates would do
right so when you forecast the cash
flows in Swiss Franks what will happen
is whatever you gain by having a lower
discount rate you will lose when you do
that conversion because your 7% growth
in US Dollars will become a 5% growth
grow in Swiss
fracks now do you see why I was okay
valueing Anka and Turkish L I did give
them Sky High discount
rates but when I came to estimating
growth I gave them a 25% growth rate you
saying that's absurd for an
infrastructure company their real growth
is only about 3 or 4% but if you think
about the inflation that's embedded in a
22% riskk free rate that inflation is
going to make your growth rates also
high if you pick a high inflation
currency you will have a high discount
rate that's a given but if you pick a
high inflation currency you also will
have much higher growth rate you can
already see the pathway to ruin your is
to mix and
match if you decide to Value the company
in US Dollars and you leave the growth
rate as the US dollar growth rate and
you discount it back at a Swiss frank
discount rate what are you going to end
up finding very high value you're going
to find the company as a very high value
for all the wrong reasons conversely
if I took a Turkish company estimated
the cash flows in dollars and used a
Turkish Le discount rate I will
devastate the
company mistakes and valuation come from
mixing and matching inflation rates
different inflation rates in your cash
flows and discount rates and that's what
you're trying to avoid so risk-free
rates vary across currencies can they
vary across
time stupid question of course it can
vary across time right the 4.5% you're
looking at the t- bond rate remember
your project is due May 5th I will make
a prediction that I'm willing to put
$10,000 behind that the t- bond rate on
May 5th is not going to be
4.5% maybe I shouldn't put 10,000 might
end up
there but you see why right it could go
up it could go down what
causes interest rates to change over
time one more but that's you know kind
very because demand so what drives B
markets pushing up rates are pushing and
please don't say the FED
not no it's actually one thing right
it's inflation and real growth it's two
things
right but basically inflation and real
growth drive it inflation goes up a lot
you should expect the t- bond rate to go
up a lot it goes down over the period
you saying what can cause inflation to
collapse there's the co
collapse between February 14th and March
20th of 2020
treasury rates in the US
imploded they went from 3% down to one
and a half they they kind of stayed down
there for a while but what is it about
Co that made treasury rates drop so
dramatically well remember covid
basically you the economy at least a few
was the economy would implode and people
would stop buying stuff deflation I mean
it turned out in hindsight was complete
fantasy
but the market was basically building in
those expectations so rates will vary
across currencies they'll vary across
time don't fight
it which fight it in the sense you want
a discount rate you want it to stay
locked over the next three months it's
not going to happen your rates are going
to be moving luckily for you you can
make your discounted C you can even put
the tond rate as a direct input from
Yahoo finance right so you don't enter
the number might not be a bad idea
because you can create an Excel
spreadsheet that's live then where your
valuation gets updated every moment of
every
day hopefully not by too much because if
a lot is happening then you're having
the equivalent of covid and a lot of
other things could change as well but
interest rates do vary across
time so if you have a currency where
there is a Government Bond we at least
have a pathway to getting risk free
rates right getting defa
spread but there are about 120
currencies around the world where there
is no Government Bond in that currency
doesn't mean those governments don't
borrow much of Africa you will not find
a 10-year government B outside of
Nigeria and South Africa you're going to
have a tough time finding a Government
Bond do those governments borrow yes
they borrow from the World Bank they
borrow from commercial Banks they don't
issue
bonds saying how do I get a risk-free
rate in those
currencies I think we've created the
pathway because if differences in risk
free rates come from difference in
inflation there's another way to get a
risk free rate that doesn't require a
Government
Bond I'll give you an example 2015 I was
valuing an Egyptian Bank why was I I
don't know I was moment of weakness I
want to Value Egyptian Bank in Egyptian
pounds and I wanted to get a risk-free
rate in Egyptian pounds I went looking
for a government bond rate in Egyptian
pounds none out there so here's how I
proceeded to get the risk free rating
pounds and tell me whether you go along
with the logic the t- bond rate then was
about 2% that's a US you're saying why
are you going to Dollar risk fre rate
I'm going to start there and then I
estimated two numbers the first was an
expected inflation rate in the US which
at that time was 1 and a half% and an
expected inflation rate in Egyptian PS
which is
15% if I'm in a hurry you know I'm done
right because basically to get a risk
free rate in Egyptian pounds I'm going
to take the US key bond rate of 2% and
add the differential inflation which in
this case would be 13 and a half% 2%
plus 13 a half% is 15 a half
per. if I wanted to get
fancy maybe to show
off risk free rates have this
compounding effect inflation and real
interest rates compound what does that
mean to get the risk fre rate I'm going
to start with one plus the USD bond rate
and then take the inflation in the two
countries and and subtract out one all
the gymnastics got me to 15.57% now now
you see why the approximation works
pretty well 155% I could have got there
quick lot sooner but it's differential
inflation fact when I showed you that
picture with Government Bond there are
some Government Bond rates there that I
don't quite
trust because in much of the world
government bonds are not not like T
bonds widely traded they're issued by
the government and banks in the country
are forced to buy the government bonds
at whatever rate the government
specifies it's not a market set rate you
know how you can check to see whether
you can trust the rate do the
differential inflation if the government
bond rate is 11% inflation is
30% that Government Bond is not so I
actually do this when I get a Government
Bond in a currency that I'm not familiar
with just to make sure that that number
is even a good starting point this will
always work with any currency all you
need is the T bond rate or a German Euro
Bond as your starting point and then a
differential inflation between that
currency and the us if it's dollars or
that currency and the Euro if it's
German Euro bond rate to get a risk-free
rate in any
currency any questions on this I do need
two numbers there right the expected
inflation in dollars the expected
inflation in Egyptian Parts the expected
inflation dollars is easy to get how do
I get
it difference between the t- bond and
the tips right I think we might have
talked about it so the tips the the t-
bond rate at the started Z
4.58% the tips rate was 2.23% that's a
2.3 35% difference I'm not going to do
any dances the market gives me that
number I'll Trust it a lot more than any
macroeconomist giving me a number
because there's real money behind this
number hundreds of billions trillions of
dollars in t- bonds so they expect
inflate yeah isn't one expected and one
observe observe no observe what these
are both expectations right the the the
tips rate the 2.23% is an expected real
interest rate over the next 10 years the
t- bond rate is an expected T bond rate
over the next 10 years so what part of
that
is it's always expected you might use
observed inflation as expected why
because you get desperate right that's
what we often do and if you ask me to
get an expected inflation in Egypt that
was my first stop and I went and looked
at the observed inflation rate in the
most recent year but if you do that you
got to be very clear on why you do I'm
going to give you a suggestion on if you
want to get an expected inflation in
countries we can do it easily and at no
cost that's a big criteria for me if you
visit the imfs or the world bank's
website they have some really good data
it's really difficult to kind of work
with the data because being user
friendly is not top of the list of
priorities but they actually have
expected inflation rates for every
country for the next 5 years years not
quite 10 but this 15% came from the
imf's forecast of inflation in Egypt for
the next 5 years am I happy with it not
really but the best I can do but
essentially that's going to drive my
risk
fre started
2022 and I walked into this class the t-
bond rate was 1 and a
half% and one of the lowest rates we'd
observed in history in fact come off a
decade where rates had been
low and it was driving people crazy to
different extents depending on how old
they
were the first reaction was 1 and a
half% is a really low
rate can I replace it with something
more normal what is normal you look at
an average over the last 10 years 20
years 50 years in fact if you look at
the last 30 years the key bond rate is
about 5 to six the question is can I
just take the RIS free rate or 1 and a
half% and replace with a normalized risk
free rate fact Duff and Phelps which are
kind of a lot of the appraises depended
on suggested this as a practice in the
period of low rates is to take the low
rate and replace it with a more normal
risk
rate some of you young might be trying
to think about doing the the opposite
now 4.6% that looks like a really high
rate at least relative to my frame of
reference can I replace it with 3% my
advice is don't mess with it and here's
what
let's suppose January 1st 2022 it's 1
and a half% is the rate you replace the
1 and a half% with a 5% normalized rate
you proceed to do your valuation with
the 5% rate lead me through what's going
to happen first your cost of equity and
cost of capital are going to be higher
right you discount the cash flows back
your odds are you're going to find the
stock to be to be expensive the value is
too low relative price you're not going
to buy the stock you know why we use the
risk free rate in this process it's
opportunity cost it's where you put your
money if you don't want to buy a stock
so in your word what are you going to do
you're not going to buy the stock and
you're going to go find that normalized
t-bond that gives you a 5% rate good
luck with that you're living in a
fantasy Universe here right this isn't
an abstraction this is an actual
opportunity cost if the opportunity cost
is 1 and a half% don't go looking for
trouble by putting in a 5% rate and the
opportunity if the if if the rate is
actually 5% don't replace with a 3% you
make the opposite mistake I'm actually
making your life easier because I'm
saying whatever the T bond rate is at
the time you do the valuation or
whatever the risk rate is just let it
ride it is an opportunity cost don't
normalize things don't try to clean up
things don't say look I'm going to make
predictions on rates people have you
know those predictions are not worth the
paper they're written on when people do
it but more significantly even if you
can you don't want to bring it into your
valuation cuz if you're right about rate
going down there are far easier ways for
you to make money right go by t-bond
Futures this is not the place to bring
in views about interest rates so I've
always pushed back against normalization
and many of you might go to work at
places where people try to normalized
rates and I want you to remember the
argument against normalization it's not
that you don't have a view on rates but
this is a valuation of a company and the
risk free rate is an opportunity cost
today
so let's take on this fed dated
challenge I told you that coming into
2021 and into
2022 wouldd come off a decade of
historically low
rates that decade had the lowest t-bond
rates of in the last century and of
course we ask people why did that happen
and especially if they watch a lot of
CNBC the answer is the Fed did it right
the story I'm sure you've read right
quantitative easing the FED
is but let's see if in fact the FED is
what kept rates slow what I've done here
the black line is actually the t- bond
R and then I constructed what I call an
intrinsic t-bond rate you saying what
the heck is an intrinsic t- bond rate
what did I say the two numbers are that
go into the interest rate inflation and
a real interest rate but in the longterm
real interest rates and real growth are
pretty much the same number so every
year I took the inflation rate that year
and the real GDP growth that year so if
your inflation rate was 2% and real GDP
growth is three 2 plus 3 is five I said
the t- bond rate should be 5% and I
graphed it up do you think the two at
least move
together there's the 1970s why were
rates high again it must have been the
FED must have been raising rates no
nothing to do with the FED inflation was
high inflation is high rais but take a
look at the last decade it's a decade
with historically low inflation it's the
lowest inflation decade we've had in the
last
century and in terms of real growth it's
a decade of anemic real growth what's
low plus low low there's your answer why
were rates low in the last decade
because you low inflation and low real
growth could the FED have an effect yes
at the
margin at the margin why did rates go up
in 2022 oh the FED must have raised
rates no the FED didn't raise rates
inflation went up rates went up the FED
then chased the market raising rates to
try to catch up with the market what
will interest rates do in 2025 frankly I
don't care what the FED does it's what
inflation will do this year and real
growth will be that will determine so if
you have a scenario where no you think
that inflation is going to increase for
whatever reason it's a macro story it's
going to show up as higher interest
rates higher t- bond
rate it could also be a story of real
growth incre inreasing next year you
know because of tax cuts that two will
cause interest rates to go
up what drives rates is fundamentals and
for 15 years now watch this discussion
devolve into what will the FED do next
week what will it do next month and I
think it's a very unhealthy discussion
because it makes it sound like the FED
sets rates that if they wanted to bring
rates down to 2% they could do it you
know the danger of this is
politicians are going to put pressure on
Central Bank saying rates are too
high you got to lower rates and you know
what happens the FED lowest rates in a
period of high
inflation you you get
turkey because that's exactly what's
happened in Turkey is every time
inflation goes up and there is no
semblance of Independence the Turkish
Central Bank there's no the FED at least
has this history that from the top comes
the the the command and rates have gone
up you guys have to lower your rate the
only rate the FED has the central bank
that has to low is like the FED funds
rate and they lower the rate and we
lower the rate what's the signal you're
sending to Market we don't care about
inflation expected inflation goes up
even more this is like you're moving in
the wrong direction because you've lost
track of what it is that
drives interest rates Julian your
question says going predicting what will
happen they're not actually no the only
rate the FED actually changes the FED
funds rate that interbank borrowing rate
so they can tell you they're going to
raise it lower it but let's face it
that's a number that none of us ever
faces the rest of the rates are set by
the market the fed's influence comes
from the fact that they do have access
to information about both inflation and
real growth you know there are 10
federal banks around the country they
collect data it's amazing amount of data
not all of it is shared with the rest of
the world but when the fed raises
rates Here's the the the mind of the
market they must be seeing something on
the ground that believe that leads them
to believe that inflation will go up
they're raising rates to try to bring
inflation down and that's almost
entirely an earned respect now that's
why this is the legacy of Paul vuler
1979 he came in and he said the only
focus of a central bank is to make sure
inflation doesn't everything else is
secondary and for 4 years in the US
people have believed that the that the
FED will put inflation front and center
in terms of deciding what to do that's
why I said the power of the FED comes
from the perception that it has power
that it is credible you take those two
away the FED stops matter in Japanese
central banks nobody cares what they do
right and a lot of the world central
banks have zero power over markets
because nobody has any faith in in them
collecting information and they have no
credibility so if nothing else you get
out of this class hopefully the next
time you see on CNBC some there are
people who have fed
Watchers their entire life is watching
the FED predicting I can't think of a
more empty Life to Live than watching
something that doesn't matter and
forecast what it will do but this has
become almost an entire exercise in
itself
right yes R so outside of sending that
signal from all the data that that is
sinking what is the real impact of
changing the repo rate on the on any
there's a very it used to be stronger 40
years ago it used to be that the FED
funds rate was connected to other rates
that were pegged to Prim the prim at one
point in time there was this rate called
the prime rate in the US the prime rate
and I remember the 80s people would talk
about the prime rate the prime rate was
a rate that Banks set that drove a lot
of the other rates that you and I faced
on our on a credit card
and stuff so in those days when the FED
actually raised rates it affected the
prime rate and through the prime rate it
affected the rate those days are done I
mean you ask people what thee you could
ask a bank what's the prime rate and
they say I have no idea we've stopped
tracking it because more of our rates
are tied to Market interest rates your
mortgage rate nothing to do with the
prime rate nothing to do with the FED
funds rate it's driven almost entirely
by what happened to the T bond rate you
look at a graph of mortgage rates versus
T bond rate they kind of move together
that's why last September when the FED
cut the FED funds rate in the 3 months
following mortgage rates didn't go down
they went up because the t- bond rate
went up
so the actual rates that are tied to the
FED funds rate are very few and limited
there are some business loans that might
be tied to the FED funds rate but it's
probably 10% of the overall loan market
and it's getting smaller so the actual
control the FED has over the rates that
you and I see and you and I includes
businesses is very limited that's why
it's almost entirely a signaling
exercise no somebody back here a
question yes go ahead Jessica long B
kind of TI like bad shortterm interest
rates because I feel like every time
that fed makes an announcement there is
like a large movement where like
longterm I think you might see this is I
think you know we have our priors
because we watch data we watch data
selectively right we watch the DAT I
think it's you know one reason I I pull
back data going back to 1954 which you
can from the Fred look at the FED funds
rate and the t- rate and the t- bond
rate is to see if my prior are right and
it turns out that the FED effect is
primarily on the short end of the
spectrum because fed funds is a
shortterm rate if there's any effect the
t- bond rate is a life of its on it
basically does whatever you know
inflation and real growth are driving it
to do that's why terms U curves can get
downward sloping is a Fed funds rate
might affect the short-term rate but the
long-term rate does whatever it
long-term rates do so the connection
between the three is very loose the
correlation is like 0.03 04 it's very
very limited much of what happens seems
to be driven by macro factors that the
FED doesn't
control it you know what why we look to
the FED as a set of makes us feel
comfortable right we think that you know
Jerome po can make our life easier right
if all he has to do is lower the rat the
economy is going to it makes us feel
more comfortable and More in control of
what's going to happen in the future the
truth is the F doesn't control the
future that's why we charge a an equity
risk premium so interest rates or
interest rates they're going to be
driven by demand and supply and
inflation
ultimately and of course we talked about
negative interest rates you kind of
asked answer the question asima
let's stop there what exactly was
quantitative easy because it must have
been more because fed has always know
controlled fed funds rate what did they
do in addition to that in 200 after 2008
that went into this quantitative
eing just influx they bought t-on that's
all they did they went in and bought t-
bonds it's a demand Supply right and you
saying if they buy t- bonds could could
they lower the rate and that's always
been the other pathway say if they buy
enough
bonds couldn't they lower the rate you
know how big the Tor Market is it's like
trillion fed can buy 100 billion people
won't even notice so the quantitative
easing at the margin Again by buying
bonds it might have lowered the rate
from 4.57% to
4.54% that's why I said at the Marg and
all of this dancing around can lower the
rate but inflation goes to 7% you can
try to buy as many bonds as you want but
t- Bond rates are climbing towards 7%
plus cuz and the reason is simple if I
buy a bond I want to make sure inflation
is covered otherwise I'm put at a
deficit even before I start so all of
the quantitative easing you look through
the processes were tweaking the rate not
changing it
fundamentally so with negative interest
rates the one question though is this is
something we hadn't seen until the last
decade and it freaks people out it
creates some really
strange you know implications there was
I think five years ago Danish
homeowners were borrowing money to buy
their houses just like you know you and
I might but the bank was mailing them
usually when you borrow money you pay
the bank every month the bank was paying
them so how can that be if you have
negative mortgage rates
the bank will send you a check every
month you think this is amazing I want
to live in this world it's kind of a
freakish World negative interest rates
are never good news because it comes
with deflation and negative real growth
you might be getting a check from the
bank but you're probably going to lose
your job and your income is going to
shrink over
time you got to play this process
through but there's the other thing
about negative interest rate that
troubles people you're putting your
money in the bank so let's say have
$100,000 you put your money in the bank
what does the bank do it takes away ,000
you're saying why would I do that why
would I just keep the money at
home that's always been the push back
against negative interest rates is since
you don't have to put your money in the
bank and earn a negative rate why don't
you just hold on to cash what's the
answer to
that let me ask you question how many of
you have cash in your pockets right
now relatively few right maybe about $5
just in case you see a homeless person
you want to give them the cash no we
don't use
cash sometimes we don't even take our
wallets with us because we've got our
phones with us one of the consequences
of being in a cashless Society is we
don't even know what to do with cash
second let's suppose that wit has $10
million in cash and he decides not to
put in the bank because they charge a
minus 1% interest rate so wi is going to
keep $10 million of cash in his
apartment where do he live with I want
to pass the message on because the next
thing you have to do is hire security
guards to protect you there's a
consequence here of having a lot of cash
so what I'm trying to say is C interest
rates can get
negative and you won't hold on to cash
because it's messy it's pain it's
dangerous but if they become minus 3%
You' probably think more seriously about
holding on to cash and hiring a security
guard so interest rates can turn
negative but there's kind of a floor at
which people will say I'm not taking
this anymore I'm just going to keep my
cash as
cash so negative interest rates can
happen there the the way I I think I I
titled this blog was uncommon but not
unnatural because people said negative
interest rates can't happen they can
it's just unusual when it happens you
got to think about what
drives so now let's talk about Equity
risk premiums I laid the foundation
right what you charge over and about
what affects it everything that happens
around you it's a receptical for all of
your hopes and fears as an
investor so right now you're looking at
the hope now is that you look at
economic growth and what what you think
it'll deliver and the uncertainty in
economic growth inflation goes in there
you worried about a crises it's in there
I won't even list them out but if you
look at it everything affects it
government policy affects it
you saying so what this number is going
to be an unstable number it's going to
change over time so any measure of an
equity risk premium you come up with
better be dynamic because to say that
your Equity RIS hasn't changed over the
last 20 years is a conf it's a Deni
you're you're in denial how can it not
change so everything affects Equity risk
Brams yeah but right
it is continuous risk but that means you
got to estimate it input it but you got
to do the work right and if you're using
a historical risk premium it's not going
to move so let's set up the process with
historical risk premiums this was the
exercise we started with so I'm going to
look backwards and I'm going to hit a
historical risk premium so at the start
of every year I compute a historical
risk premium on my web page why because
I refuse to pay somebody for a risk
premium the data is already out there I
never use these historical premiums but
in case you're inclined to go with the
past I have the numbers for you the
historical Equity risk premiums for the
US keyword is premiums not
premium is somewhere between five and
14% you saying how can you have multiple
Equity risk PRS for the same Market it
depends on the slides of History you
look at I've looked at three possible
slices 1928 is my starting year and your
50 years and 10 years I've also looked
at the equity risk premium over t- bills
as opposed to t- bonds t- bills are
shortterm treasuries 3 months six and
these are three Monon t- BS t- bonds are
10e t- bonds the premiums are different
it even depends on how I compute my
average returns see what does that even
mean if I give you 100 Years of stock
returns easy way to compute an average
is add the 100 numbers up divide by 100
right simple
average but the problem with doing that
is returns are
compounding I'll give you a very simple
example to see how the compounding plays
out let's say you have stocks double in
your one what was the return that year
if they doubled plus 100% And then they
have the year
after minus 50% right so how much money
do you make over the two years nothing
about but if I through the magic of
arithmetic averaging you made a 25%
return you just don't know it 100 - 50
is 50 / 2 arithmetic averages missed the
compounding effect so what can you do
you can do what's called a compounded
average jric average we look at your
starting number your ending number and
you look at what you make so if you
start at 100 you ended at 100 I'm not
going to try to fool you by saying you
made any money you did
not so you got how far back do you go t-
bills or t bonds arithmetical geometric
averages already you can see the danger
of historical risk premiums remember we
talked about
bias asima let's say you are an
appraiser for a private business that's
up for splitting in half because it's in
the middle of a divorce you want a low
number right for your client so which
are these numbers you going to latch on
to high highest number or lowest Equity
risk
premium highest because you want the
discount rate to be high so you're going
to pick 134% I ask you why it came out
of deodrant historical risk put that in
because you can blame me that right
conversely if you want a really high
number for your value you're an equity
research and you want to convince me inv
video cheap you can leatch on to maybe
the lowest number
5.44% if I let you pick and choose
you're going to pick whatever number
justifies and you be amazed and how much
bias plays out in this
process so if you're going to use
historical risk prams I'm going to put
some guardrails on what to do
first you have to go back as far in time
as you can it's a pure statistical
reason remember I said every estimate of
an average comes with a standard error
I've actually estimated the standard
error with each of these numbers and
notice as I go from 100 close to 100
years to 50 to 10 the standard error is
getting
larger pure pure so if you want at least
a reasonable chance of getting the risk
premium right better not use a 10year
premium the noise in that is going to be
so large that the range you get will be
useless but even with a 100 years
because of data I'm ending up with the
risk standard ER of 2. two roughly 2%
hold on to that thought because I'm
going to complete the other two things I
want you to do second this is an equity
risk you're going to use in your
calculations right and remember when we
when we talked about valuation we talked
about what the right risk- free rate to
use was did we pick tbls or t
bonds and and the reason is valuation is
long term so I'm going to take the
tables out of the pictures this is good
I'm getting rid of the numbers I can't
use so I want to go back as far as I can
and I want to use t-bonds final question
this number is going to go into a
discount rate and what happens that
discount rate I use to Discount year one
then year two it's going to compound
over time I think logic alone drives you
towards a geometric average so t- Bond's
longest time period geometric average
5.44% we talk about false Precision in
valuation 0 44% I'm getting a little
carried away with the Precision here
you know why this is false Precision
that's my estimate of the equity risk
beim going back close to 100 years
geometric average stocks versus debonds
but here's a dirty little secret I'm not
letting you in on the standard error is
roughly 2.1% so if I tell you the equity
risk premium is 5.4% and then I say oh
by the way I forgot to tell you that the
standard ER is
2.1% do you want to quantify what that
means to me if I have a 2.1% stand
standard statistics what do we do to get
an estimate of the
range to I think like about 4 point no
let's not go that far two standard
errors will get me to 95% confidence
which means My Equity risk Fram for the
US with a 100 Years of History even if I
assume me reversion works is somewhere
between 1 and 10% right fat lot of good
that does you in evaluation your equ
some you'd fire me on the spot I were
estimator saying what good is that to me
but that's what you're doing every time
you use a historical risk premium
because nobody's talking about the
standard
era so as I told you at the start of
this class I'm going to dig a hole for
historical risk PRS and going to bury
them the first problem is this this
standard noisy
has and if you have trouble in the US
think of how much more Troublesome this
is going to be if I ask you what the
equity risk premium is for Vietnam
or even much of Europe because you
didn't you had that break between 1940
and 45 many European markets shut down
it's not even a choice you can't even go
back there and second by using the US
market I've opened myself to what's
called survivorship
buyers what is the most successful
Equity Market of the 20th century it was
the US Equity Market I picked the equity
risk premium for the most successful
Market of the 20th century what am I
going to do
in 2024 I'm going to use it for the next
Century but in in you went back in 1901
and you had money to invest you could
have chosen to invest in the US market
but the US market wasn't the biggest
Market in the world there it might have
been the UK Market or the Austrian
Market you had no way of knowing what
the best Market of the centur would
be you know what that implies right if
you take an equity risk premium for the
most successful Market in the world are
you going to overstate the premium or
understate
it you're going to overstate it why
because you've taken the most successful
Market you have no idea what the most
successful Market will be the next
Century that's a survivorship
bias and if this problem is bad with the
us we have all this historical data
think of how much worse it gets if I ask
you to estimate an equity risk premium
for a market without much history
so at least I want to lay the
foundations for if I want an equity risk
premium for Brazil or Vietnam or India
or Indonesia or
Poland given that this historical data
is not even a start here you think but
India is historical data going back you
take a look at the Indian Equity Market
in 1968 and come back and tell me you
got historical data it was a market of
maybe 20 companies with very little
liquidity you don't have much historical
data so you have two choices if I am a
Brazilian company and I ask you to come
in value first is you can ask me to come
back in a 100 years so by then I'll have
enough historical data of your Market or
you can try to do something today I
think the ladder is a better strategy to
adopt so I'm going to give you three
ways in which I'm going to try to
estimate Equity risk premiums for
markets outside the US in the first I
start with the US Equity risk with all
my qualms about what it is let's suppose
I feel reasonably okay with this number
so let's work this out intuitively if my
Equity risk for the US is 5.44% today
that's a historical premium and I say
would you and you're investing in Brazil
would you require a larger premium or a
smaller premium every degree larger why
because remember all those things I
talked about the drive Equity
risk those are all much greater in
Brazil than in the US or larger that was
the easy part now the question is how
much larger here's the the first and the
easiest answer it comes with limitations
it's a number we've already
used when we computed risk free rates
for Brazil what do we do we started with
the government bond rate and we
subtracted out the default spread it's
number like Waldo it's going to come
back
again and basically if you take that
number and add it to the US Equity risk
premium you have an equity risk premium
for berser so if you remember the number
I got was 2.83% with the the third
approach let's suppose that's the
approach I used on the risk free rate
and that's where consistency is going to
kick in if you used a different number
in the risk free rate stay with that
number if that was the number I used to
clean up the government bond rate I'm
going to take that number and add it on
to the US premium you say where did the
4.33% come from I'll talk about that but
it's a number that I think I feel more
comfortable with as My Equity risk Prem
for the
US I add the 2.83% to it and I get an
equity risk premium for Brazil of
7.16% this is the state ofthe art if you
can call it that in how appraisers
analysts and bankers estimate Equity
risk premiums for other countries they
take a US premium God only knows where
that comes from or you know how unstable
it is and they add a default spread
either using the Sovereign CDs spread or
the ratings based approach or a
Government Bond spread go ahead and say
I'm
done what's you know clearly it's a
simple approach the numbers are easy to
get what what are the what are the
problems this approach fundamentally or
intuitively what do you think the
problem with this approaches yes
or it's based on the government
basically the 2.83% is what I would
charge for buying a Brazilian Government
Bond right the extra amount because it's
risky but I'm not buying a bond I'm
buying Brazilian equities so de should
help me out if uh you know and 2.83% is
what I'm charging for buying a govern
Bond and I'm thinking about Brazilian
equities are equities riskier than bonds
generally sa they probably should be
risky so I would expect the risk premium
to be larger because I'm talking about
equities so that was the first thing
that bothered me when I saw this
approach because it was the default
approach I saw it used everywhere so
I'll give you the pathway I
took but Goldman Sachs about 30 plus
years ago said why even look at the
Government Bond there's a different way
in which I can get an equity risk for
braz though and here's what they did
they to they comp they came up with the
historical standard backward looking but
historical standard deviations in the US
Equity index the S&P 500 and the baspa
so let's assume the standard deviation
the basa is
30% and the standard deviation in the
S&P 500 is
18% Let's do an algebra problem if
you're buying the 18% Market which is
the US market you're charging a 4.33%
premium right but even instead you want
to buy the Brazilian Market which is
roughly what 1.67 times more volatile 30
over 18 1.67 * 4.33% gives me an equity
risk premium for Brazil of
7.22% no when this came out people said
this is great we're not looking at the
bond market we're staying with an equity
but this approach has a fatal
problem do you know what it is anybody
want to guess what the problem is what
is it based on standard deviation of the
S&P 5 standard deviation of the local
Equity Index right think about what goes
in the standard deviation local Equity
index obviously it's all the risk in the
country but for prices to move something
has to happen which is people have to
trade in a market where there is zero
trading the standard deviation will
Converge on
zero I computed this number for the
Bangladeshi Equity market last year and
it's about 5% standard deviation if I
stayed with this approach I'm going to
be giving the equity risk premium for
banglades to be onethird of the equity
risk charging for the US which is
absurd because you comparing Market with
very different
liquidity I've you know every year I
take this approach I compute the equity
risk every Market about a third of the
market look at there no way am itim
investing in those markets CU what I'm
getting is a reflection of the liquidity
of the market not the risk of the
market so I'm going to give you my third
approach this is my default approach I
won't claim that it's the best approach
but it's an approach where I tried to
negotiate what I can in terms of
compromises I start with the 4.33% just
like it in the first approach but
instead of adding the 2.83% to it I
scale up the 2.83% for how much riskier
stocks are relative to bonds within the
Brazilian Market you say how do you do
with the liqu liquidity issue if there's
light liquidity in one market there's
probably light liquidity in the other
Market the Bangladeshi Equity Market has
very little liquidity but so is the
Bangladeshi Government
Bond at least I'm comparing Apples to
Apples that
ratio for Brazil was about 1.5 the
Brazilian Equity index was 1.5 times
more B than the Brazilian government
Bond yeah simple so for standard
deviation how far are you going it
doesn't matter use the same for both
right it that's a it's a ratio that
matters right so unless you believe the
ratio is going to be off if you use 6
months use two years then it's basically
a sense of how much riskier are equities
and bonds within this Market that number
gives me 8.58% very different numbers
that's a number you'd see in my
valuation and if you use one of the
other two approaches I'm not going to
say you're wrong it's just a different
it's not going to make or break your
valuation but I think you need to pick
an approach that works across all
countries not one that just works on
this country because you might have to
do this on seven different countries for
your
company and you got to make sure it's so
this is an exercise at the start of
every year that I go
through I yeah go ahead Margaret does
this require basically like going back
to the country I have to issue a
us-based it doesn't have to be it can be
a local B it has to be traded there has
to be government Wars traded and there
in lies a promt that's available for
only what what 37 countries that he saw
you saying what do you do with the rest
I'll talk about what I end up doing in
practice because it's very messy staying
with local government bonds trying to
get this for every country so started
2025 like I have I think it started this
for the first time in 1992 so it's kind
of a 33-year old database most widely
the most downloaded data set on my
website I want to computer Equity
screams my country I start with the US
premium and I as I said I'll come back
and back into the 4.33% that's my
starting point then I look up The
Sovereign local currency rating remember
I said there are two ratings for every
country local currency and foreign
currency I look up the local currency
rating your country if you're AAA
rated I classify you as a mature market
and I give you exactly the same Equity
risk premium as the US why because if
you have 10 mature markets with
different Equity risk premiums money is
going to flow across them and even out
the premiums so every AAA rated country
is going to get the same premi us so
let's name some AAA rated countries
let's see how many you can come up with
let's start with Europe there are quite
a
few all of you can go so don't even look
to the South there's nothing there right
so start Germany work upwards so you got
Germany
Netherlands Switzerland
Sweden they all get 4.33% prems let's
move over to Asia there's only one
country in Asia with a AAA rating which
is Singapore right go go to to Australia
New Zealand both AAA rated come to North
America you got Canada you got the us
both AAA rated us less AAA rated than
Canada because you got three different
ratings agencies and only Moody still
gives a AAA rating but I'll hold on to
that for the moment and then you go to
Latin America don't even look for
Ratings than a in it and it's going to
be be something know basically good I
think Chile might be the only one that's
tipped over into the a scale but not no
AAA rating countries for those countries
which don't have AAA ratings here's what
I do I take the rating and I come up
with a default spread if that sounds
familiar that's how I got the 2.83% for
Brazil right that lookup table I look at
the default spread when I first started
doing this I then would go look for
looking for a Government Bond and Equity
index in each country and as Margaret
pointed out two problems one is a lot of
countries don't have government bonds
and in the countries that do have
government bonds many are not traded so
I started cheating about 20 years ago
and I haven't stopped instead of looking
up each country I look up two indices
one is an S&P index of emerging market
equities it's actually a widely invested
in index you can get the price every day
so you go to the S&P website you can
download the data for The Last 5 Years
actually download for the last two
years and then I found and this was pure
luck I found an ETF that invests only in
Emerging Market government
bonds which is St it's I can get the
price and I looked up the standard
deviation the ETF and you can see where
I went next I took the the Emerging
Market Equity index divided by the
Emerging Market Bond index and I came up
with 1.35 what does that tell me based
on those numbers I'm going to take the
default spread you have as a company
let's say it's 2% multiply by
1.35 it makes me
2.7% add it on to the
4.33% I've got an equity risk premium
for your country question but isn't it a
stretch Dr that there are lots of
stretches here right but what's so what
what is the part that you would
unstretch no no tell me so what's the
part that's the stret the
1.35 would be same so what's your
alternative to
that okay so I think that when you make
stretches it's because there's no easy
answer right of course I agree right but
if you decide and there are people say
well I'm not use the 1.35 at all because
it's too much of a stretch and you know
what they end up doing using just the
default spread is one any better than
1.35 isn't that a stretch sometimes
people think if you don't make an
assumption you say but you always have
to make an assumption when you use one
as your ratio you are making an
assumption I think I'm on safeer ground
assuming Equity is riskier than
government bonds so this is a number I
wrestle with every single year I've
changed the way I do this because the
data has improved but it's a work in
progress so here's what the world look
like to me at the start of 2025 pick
your favorite part of the world or your
least favorite part and let's go on a
trip I'm sorry you don't have your name
play what's your name
again Y is a Brazilian right so let's go
through Latin America exciting place
this is like a jungle ride and on Disney
there's what Latin America looks like
there is a AAA rated country in the
safest market so basically the way to
read there's the rating which gives me
the the country risk premium so the
country risk premium is the default
spread times 1.35 and added to the 4.33%
gives me the equity risk P safest Market
if you include this is Chile right
historically that's been true the and
why is the aqu SP so low because the
rating is high there's no intellectual
Firepower here right basically it's
driven by the rate the riskiest Market
probably no surprises yeah you got a tie
between Venezuela is probably at at the
very PE 28 that's your risk premium
think of what happens to your discount
rates even if you do things in dollar
terms
27.6% and you got Argentina you know har
has a lot of work to do and basically
you can see the variations across that
Amica and he say what is this number for
all of Latin America it's a weighted
average weighted by what by the GD D pce
of the countries Brazil and Argentina
obviously count or Brazil at least
counts for a lot more than everybody
else because it's a larger and I do this
for every part of the world but let me
complete the process you saying what is
that black box at the
top take a look at the countries and
you're very quickly going to see what
they have in common Guinea BAU Guyana
Haiti Iran North
Korea Liberia Libya Madagascar Malawi
Myanmar Russia Sierra Leon these are
called Frontier markets what do they
share in
common they don't have a rating why do
they not have a rating let's play it out
let's suppose you take a job at Moody's
the first day at work your boss calls
you and says I'm going to give you a
country to rate you're excited first day
you give where am I going you're hoping
for
Switzerland and they say you're going to
North
Korea you probably quit on the spot
right there's a reason they don't have a
rating the rating ages throw up their
hands Russia used to be in the rated
column it's gone because starting in
2022 the ratings agencies have just
thrown up their hands and for the
longest
time I did not compute risk premiums for
those countries and my defense was
there's no
rating but starting about 10 years ago I
said that's not fair you might have
business in
Syria or in North Korea I don't know
what kind of business it is but some
business and he need an equity risk PR
so here's the process by which I
estimate Equity risk BRS for those
countries
there are these services that measure
country risk scores The Economist does
it I use a service called political risk
services not because it's better or
worse but because I've used it for a
long time I'm comfortable with how they
do the numbers their scores go from low
to high low being the riskiest countries
High being safe last year for instance
the highest core country the the safest
country was
Switzerland the riskiest was a tie
between Sudan and South Sudan and
somewhere over
there I found and they have political
risk scores for North Korea and Syria
and countries which don't have a raid so
I look up that country risk score and
they talked about stretches I'm going to
do a real stretch say okay I know the
country risk score for Libya let's not
take a different Sierra Leon is
59.5 I go looking for countries which
scores between 55 and
60 I found five three of those countries
had ratings and had estimated an equity
risk premium for them
so complete the process what do you
think I
did I took the average across to three I
attached liya and Si I'm done is it a
stretch absolutely but if you can find a
better way of estimating Equity risk
rooms in North Korea I'd love to your
ideas
here but I have a number no matter where
you operate in the world I can say this
is what the equity risk premum looks
like I told you this the most widely
downloaded data set on my it gets used
in the strangest
places sometimes I can track where
people are coming onto my way you know
one month Lithuania usually the top is
you know nice thing about having people
in India follow you is that already
pushes the numbers of indias at the top
but then you the English speaking us UK
Australia but Lithuania was on top of
the list I said what the hell is
happening in Lithuania why they looking
up my risk premiums and it turned out
that for a period privatizations in
Lithuania you were required to use My
Equity I have no control over this
[Music]
process so this gets used in strange
places in bad ways I claim no
responsibility for it but at least now
if you run into an equity risk from
claiming to come from my web page people
have visions of me doing country risk
analysis all year I have zero interest
in doing country risk analysis I have
zero skills in that you know why and
sometimes people get pissed off at me
because I gave their country a really
high Equity risk premium people argue
with me I'm we're safer than this
neighboring country how come I RIS I am
not the one who's doing this Moody is
doing this to you because I'm starting
with your rating so if you're from
turkey and you don't like the fact that
your equ risk is higher than
Greece I'm not the one who signed it
basically a function of
ratings and Greece used to be a lot
worse than you are right now 10 years
ago and they've moved in the right
direction because the ratings have
improved so if you get a
chance take a look at the Excel
spreadsheet that contains this data
because it contains all of the raw
pieces that go in and it gives you
options you don't like ratings I give
you Sovereign CDs sprads as an
alternative but next session we're going
to talk about what to do with these
Equity risk means and value individual
companies
here